bon ils l'ont peut-être un peu cherché
les hommes politiques aussi ils ont
peut-être pas sans peut-être pas mis au
goût du jour j'étends montré des hommes
politiques là tu vas voir Laurent Baffie
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez pratiqué le double
jeu vous en politique qu'est-ce que vous
appelez le double jeu les promesses
électorales à la langue de bois les
magouilles
bon on va se tutoyer ce sera plus
convivial ok donc tu penses que toi il y
a trop de double jeu dans la politique
est-ce que pour faire des il faut
coucher pour réussir je connais pas ça
il faut décrocher avec toute la
population je crois que il faut un
nouveau langage il faut une nouvelle vue
de la France ils font un patriotisme de
son pays et de la défense des intérêts
alors on coupe tout et j'aimerais
le double jeu en politique pourquoi pour
vous c'est quoi le double jeu monsieur
il faut pas le jouer vous voulez jouer
vous monsieur
on va parler plus vrai plus direct on va
se tutoyer c'est plus convivial ok donc
qu'est-ce que tu penses du double jeu
toi c'est-à-dire les magouilles tout ça
tu as touché toi tu as touché les yeux
dans les yeux de quoi
il y a pas d'enveloppe qui passe en
dessous mais vous n'avez que ça à dire
aux hommes politiques le double champ
politique pour vous c'est quoi je ne
sais pas je ne le pratique pas Édouard
tu ne pratique un peu il est vrai que
les Français n'aiment pas toujours
entendre un syndrome de vérité et que
ils ont souvent au bout du compte les
parlementaires qui le méritent tout le
monde a décroché à votre phrase était
longue c'est peut-être un petit peu ça
aussi la langue de bois non non parce
que on ne résume pas une situation par
des formules très courtes par des gros
titres à sensations non je crois que
d'un autre côté on a pas compris une
drogue de ce que vous avez dit c'est
vous qui le dites moi je sous-estime pas
l'intelligence des Français et la
capacité qu'ils ont de comprendre des
phrases longues si vous n'êtes pas
capable vous de comprendre des phrases
longues moi je n'y peux rien essayons le
track accessible toi raconter crack
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que je veux
vocabulaire débile vous alimentez je
crois effectivement toute cette sorte
d'attitude à la fois ironique critique
dans les questions c'est vrai que je
décroche je m'excuse je décroche moi
aussi je décroche mais le journaliste me
rock'n'roll non on va la refaire on va
se tutoyer c'est plus convivial c'est
comment votre prénom Robert ok je vais
t'appeler Bobby Bobby Bobby le double
jeu tu en penses quoi
ben j'en pense peu de choses
et je pense que c'est pas du tout ce qui
fait gagner en politique
j'essaie pas de conneries le moins
possible merci baby les régimes qui
pratiquent la langue de bois je suis
dégueulasse ce point-là non c'est des
pellicules on sait pas trop chier dans
la Creuse c'est pas trop
je vous invite on fait du boulot
vous organisez des clubs
[Musique]
pour conclure écoutez ce n'est pas une
question sérieuse posez-nous une
question sur la France vous répondez
pour moi sérieuse parce que des fois on
est sur un coup on est sur le on est à
deux doigts et l'ananas se casse je
comprends pas du tout le sens de vos
questions parfois il y a des nanas qui
sont impressionnés des nanas qu'on
aurait pas forcément tiré mais comme on
le député hop on peut leur mettre une
cartouche c'est une plaisanterie là non
non c'est une vraie question monsieur
juste une question vous vous teniez la
main est-ce qu'il y a des relations
homosexuelles parmi les hommes
politiques
ou ce n'est pas la main d'abord si vous
êtes caresser un petit peu vous avez eu
un début moi je vous ai vu vous êtes
terrible une question Jean-Pierre quand
on est connu c'est plus facile avec les
gonzesses mais c'est plus difficile
c'est forcément plus difficile parce
qu'il faut mettre des lunettes noires
vraiment une question quand on est homme
politique est-ce que c'est plus facile
avec les gonzesses après
on n'a pas vécu ensemble comme ça parce
que j'ai pas volé vous êtes ensemble
avec j'adore Yvette et je crois que ça
vaut mieux l'adorer que tout le reste
qu'elle est bonne il va être je sais pas
Jacques simplement est-ce que le fait
d'être connu en politique ça sert avec
les gonzesses
c'est à dire que depuis
que j'ai rencontré ma femme qui est
fantastique alors les gonzesses ne me
concernent plus du tout plus du tout tu
t'es fait couper par un véto oh pas du
tout vraiment je te vois pas alors hein
pas rock'n'roll et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater
vous et mettez un pouce bleu